Mars the red planet a lonely planet and
as far as we know completely devoid of
life rocks dust and the occasional
man-made Rover a rule that inhabit the
surface perhaps they're not the most
obvious setting for a video game but
maybe it should be I recently read the
Martian by Andrew we're and it's a
fantastic book and said to be a major
feature film later on this year starring
matt damon and sean his character isn't
even on Mars but I bet he still dies
somehow I've been it tells the story of
Mark Watney an astronaut one of the
first people to walk on Mars and surely
the first person to die there after
becoming stranded alone now don't worry
I'm gonna keep this video free of any
major plot spoilers but the story begins
with Mark being left for dead following
an attempt by himself and the rest of
the crew to leave the planet during a
deadly dust storm oh also because
there's obviously no footage of this
fictional game instead you get to enjoy
lots of shots of me walking on Mars
I'm pretty much [ __ ] that's my
considered opinion this is watney's
initial assessment of the situation and
from this point on the book revolves
around his bid for survival relying only
on his wits and the NASA equipment and
habitat left behind which is only
designed to last for 31 days Watney
needs to constantly manage his resources
keeping everything working and devise a
plan to get off the planet and back to
earth so achievable goals as what he
puts it if the oxygenator breaks down
I'll suffocate if the water reclaimer
breaks down I'll die of thirst if the
hab breaches up just kind of explode if
none of those things happen I'll
eventually run out of food and starve to
death and this is the key to why I think
this can be a really cool game imagine a
first-person experience something a bit
like the vanishing of Ethan Carter meets
mist meets spacewalk combined with an
isometric resource management sim / FTL
kind of game you would move around the
habitat or hab in first-person view
fixing things and solving problems this
would extend to whenever you needed to
conduct an EV a or extra vehicular
activity in other words taking a stroll
on the planet's surface imagine suiting
up stepping into the airlock and then
emerging onto the Martian surface all
without breaking first-person pretty
cool the problem with only first person
though is that constantly running back
and forth managing essential systems
would be kind of a pain and probably not
much fun so when you interact with a hab
computer the game would zoom out to an
isometric view of the whole base
allowing you to manage all of your
resources from there this view would
kind of be a minigame all about juggling
your essential systems in order to
survive as well as weather storms and
other hazards thrown at you by the alien
environment like the book though the key
would be in the game's scientific
accuracy and a simulation style of play
the whole thing actually you'd be a
great fit for VR as both first person
and isometric gameplay can work great it
would really help create that feeling of
complete loneliness on an alien world
perhaps the best thing about the book
though is what knee himself his
personality his ingenuity and above all
his ability to crack jokes in the face
of certain death
excerpts from the book read as an inner
monologue to the player could be a nice
way of incorporating the fantastic
storytelling into this compelling
premise so what would be your aims in
the Martian the video game well there
would be set missions to achieve first
off re-establish contact with earth then
you'd have to solve the lack of food
problem and after that basically just
survive for as long as possible part of
this survival thing would be a time
mechanic days or souls as they're cold
on Mars literally tick by as you make
your bid for survival on the Red Planet
ultimately of course the end goal would
be to make it back to earth if you can
figure out a way so what do you think
would you play the Martian the video
game do you have any suggestions about
how to make this better or even a
completely different approach let me
know in the comments below oh and if
this is left you hungry for a Martian
video game experience then you could
always take a look at take on Mars in
the game you pilot robot rovers on the
surface it's a pretty cool stimulation
and surprisingly true to life oh and of
course read the book did I mention it's
fantastic reality check will of course
return in two weeks time as I'm now
sharing this Friday slot with Danny
O'Dwyer and it's fantastic show the
points so he'll be here next week and
I'll see you guys soon
by travelpod member